welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who now sits
on a throng bet for a king and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the book of boba fett
episode 1. first bit of amazing trivia
for you though the book of boba fett
isn't a book it's a show
however beyond that there's a ton of
easter eggs and callbacks to all things
star wars that we're going to be going
through in this video if the intro
hasn't put you off then we'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and make sure
you subscribe for breakdowns like this
every wednesday what are you waiting for
we're gonna be going over the show for
the next seven weeks and as you know it
takes two to django so i'd love to have
you as part of our alliance without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the book of boba fett
okay so just in case you missed the
mandalorian season 2 we watched as mando
trekked across the galaxy trying to find
the jedi so that baby yoda could start
his training along the way he ran into
cop vanth who he learned to take in
barbara's armor even if it didn't fit
right after helping him to defeat a
great dragon mano took the armor from
him and this sent fed out on a journey
to take it back teamed with fennic shand
he ended up joining forces with mando to
help rescue baby yoda and alongside cara
june bokutan and eventually luke
skywalker the crew got him back from the
clutches of the empire but it wasn't
over for fete and the second season
ended with him taking jabba's throne
from pip fortuna which is where we
pretty much pick up here now we start
off in the halls of jabba's palace and
see that it's no longer thriving like it
once was the halls are pretty much empty
and we catch barbara in a back to tank
with the tube in his mouth similar to
how we saw luke when he was recovering
during the empire strikes back this
explains how the character has less
scars on his face than he did in the
mandalorian and why the guy is started
looking slightly better just slightly
now kurt dicamino aka where the clones
were all created and we see slave one
docked there in case you missed the bad
batch we actually watched the
destruction of this as the empire
decided that clones were no longer
needed due to the cost they incurred
they realized that recruiting regular
citizens was the best way to go about
things and thus slowly replace the
clones over time during these flashbacks
we also see moments from attack of the
clones namely when boba picked up his
father's helmet helmets and their
importance are laced throughout this
episode and it's sort of like poetry yes
we've brought that back beyond that
though we also learned what happened to
fett when he was trapped in the sarlacc
pit the iconography here pulls from the
expanded little book above like that the
tale of boba fett in the original legend
series boba melded his mind with the
sarlacc and had some back and forth
before detonating his jetpack in order
to escape here however he takes the
oxygen from a stormtrooper and burns his
way out from the inside i don't know how
a stormtrooper managed to get trapped
inside but you have to remember that the
digestion period of the sarlacc lasts
for thousands of years so he might have
fallen in there all the way back in a
new hope or even before that as boba
climbs out the pit we get lots of nods
to the artwork from the expanded lauren
comic series and i even think they might
have given nods to the fan films that
were created as it definitely feels like
they're paying homage to how it's been
depicted before they're also doing it
better than it's ever been done before
though and just seeing the sang
completely cover his armor looks really
really gritty i hate sand it gets
everywhere now unfortunately there's no
sarlacc head which was an addition that
lucas added in for the special editions
amongst the runes of jabba's sail board
she's picked up by jawas which is of
course how cobb band came to get the
armor in the mandalorian they abandoned
him and he's saved by some people sorry
tuscan raiders
and we'll have to make that clear
because we're inclusive at the channel
given the food of the desert they then
drag him on panthers and i got a lot of
flashes here of the desert scene from
the good the bad and the ugly star wars
has always given nods to westerns and
watching him being dragged along during
a sandstorm is just as grueling as it is
in that movie the twin suns beat down on
him and they're of course something that
tatooine is most famous for at this
point we get the title of the episode
stranger in a strange land based on the
book of the same name this was about a
man that was raised on mars who then
ventured to earth here he questioned
society and how it was run namely with
the importance put on religion and money
and much like fett we watched as he
attempted to rewrite the rules we're
introduced to a tuscan kid who darth
vader is probably going to kill to
impress a woman we also meet their chief
and at one point see that they have
herodian who you might recognize as
being the same species as greedo beyond
that though we also see that they have a
massive who's a massive guard dog that
the tuscans keep around as much as the
mandalorian made the tuscan raiders seem
like civilized people they clearly
aren't also surely sand people is the
less offensive term yet because raiders
just sounds horrible anyway moving on
now fett tries to escape but your boy
isn't playing around and i've always
appreciated the alligator like jaw
design to these massive beasts that
shows he's not one to django with and he
takes the creature out pretty easily
before offering the rodian a chance to
escape unfortunately he's a snitch and
he calls out to the
tusk san people and whereas the child
was happy beating the crap out of boba
boba stays his hand and though he's
caught the situation does slightly
change for him unfortunately these
flashbacks are interrupted but we get an
awesome suiting up scene in which he's
dressed by droids having their clothes
put on by servants is something that
royalty and the emperors of old used to
do and it shows that he's very much
building a kingdom aliens of all kind
have traveled to the palace to pay their
respects and there's a lot of godfather
vibes throughout this whole scene we see
that though they don't have a protocol
droid to translate things they do have
88 who you might recognize as being
jabba's smelting droid we also meet doc
strassie a trans ocean who you might
recognize as being the same species as
bosk he calls fed daimyo and shout out
simon a bearman on twitter for pointing
out that this is a word from feudal
japan that means lord he's brought gifts
to welcome him to most esper and this
may be a wookiee skin though it's
difficult to make out the snake voice
doc has also makes him sound like he's
threatening fett but that ain't the real
shade now we discovered that the mayor
won't come or offer a tribute to fete
because he wants one instead this kind
of sets things up for later in the
series and we watch his two gamorean
gods are brought before them it's
advised that they be tortured but
instead fett recognizes their loyalty
and wants them by his side they mask up
and head out to mouse esper which is
where we venture to the sanctuary and
see that your boy max rebo has continued
busting those keys what happened to rebo
has always been a big mystery but it's
great seeing him here doing what he
loves to do alongside him is abith from
the cantina band and i kinda hope these
two met up and decided to collab with a
new group just not the one from star
wars visions yeah as that was terrible
now most esper was also where anakin
grew up and it's changed quite a lot
since we last saw it unlike the dark and
dingy cantina in mos
this one seems a lot brighter has droids
in it and also some plants if you cast
your mind back to a new hope then you
might remember that droids were banned
from the cantina but in the mandalorian
we saw that one was now working there
meaning that times had changed we see an
astromech one serving drinks which is
also similar to r2d2 doing it on jabba's
barge two members of staff approach and
offered a clean fet's helmet which in
england means something different to
what it does in star wars now they're
here to meet madame garcia however these
helmets being filled up causes some
issues later on and it may have been
done on purpose garsa is also a twilike
and it shows that the positions of power
have slightly changed as in jabba's
palace he of course had one tied up i
know that these aliens did have power
throughout the galaxy but i do feel like
the race was chosen for a reason to kind
of demonstrate how things had changed on
tatooine now it was expected that fett
would have been carried in and much like
the empress of old this is something
that was often done by servants vet
wants to walk on his own two feet though
showing how he's changed things he's
handing back his helmet which is filled
with coins that have the rebellion crest
on them showing that they now run the
galaxy now outside fennick and boba talk
about jabba and his vassals according to
google a vassal is a person under the
protection of a feudal lord to whom he
has vowed to pay tribute to we learned
that jabba had a lot of different
aspects to his empire and that keeping
them all in check will be quite
difficult however whereas jabba would
kill you if he didn't do the right dance
move boba intends true with respect what
what was that dance movie the jabba
jabba the strut
now at this point they're in now so bad
now at this point they're ambushed by
warriors which leads to our first major
action scene the red shields that they
use here actually look very similar the
shield blast doors that were seen in the
phantom menace this red force feel can
stop anything including lightsabers and
the scene actually reminds me a lot of
when police try and break up a riot in
the way that they have battens and
shields in front of them when it seems
like they're cornered the gomorian gods
come to the rescue showing that fear was
right to spare their lives your boy puts
on his mean face and alongside shan and
the gods they do make light work of most
of them however fett is badly injured
during this and though he completely
vaporizes one of them he wants one
brought in alive shan chases them down
across the rooftop showcasing some of
the skills that we saw her pulling off
in the bad batch they go full parkour
and we watch them swinging through the
skyline of most esper shan catches them
both but as she just needs one she kicks
the other off the edge of the roof boba
is taken back to the tank and we get
more flashbacks of his time with her the
people in the desert now the young boy
he didn't beat the crap out of is
slightly more sympathetic towards him
and he leads him in the rhodium prisoner
out into the desert they come across
sweet bikes riding a home and there's of
course a lot of call backs to a new hope
here namely luke's house and the black
smoke rising from it they're instructed
to dig for water and the episode kind of
slows down at this point but you know
what i was still really enjoying being
back in this world the rodian keeps
getting more and more water stones is it
water stones and when baba finds one he
drinks from it he calls the kid a
youngling which is of course the name
for children in the star wars universe
perfect he just ends up in alderaan
places and with a guy this greedo he's
lucky to get any water at all hey now
fair is furious that they could have
escaped and he also mentions anchor head
which is a small town on tatooine often
used for transportation the rodion ends
up digging too deep though and a beast
amongst the sand rises up and rips him
in the mass of a new one fett manages to
save the youngling and kill the creature
by strangling it with a chain much like
what he threatened to do to the rhodian
he's won the respect of the raiders
sorry if there's any raiders watching
this and the child returns to the camp
with pep freed from his chains and the
monster's head we know from the end of
the mandalorians season two episode one
that fett had weapons of the sam people
and therefore we kind of knew that he
got accepted amongst them fett is given
water as a sign to show that he's an
equal as in the desert this is of course
a very precious commodity that ends the
episode with us basically getting the
same ending as june and we get that
awesome theme tune which kicks in
now as for my thoughts on the episode i
thought this was a great first entry and
the disney plus star wars shows have
continued to be really atmospheric and
not only nostalgic on a number of levels
but also highly intriguing and how
they're going to advance the story as
much as i love watching the jedi and the
characters in the main trilogy the side
of star wars that has always fascinated
me the most is the darker gangster heavy
criminal stories that exist through
certain characters growing up shadows of
the empire was one of my favorite books
and games and i was absolutely obsessed
with the more low-level criminal
organizations that existed just outside
the empire they really had some
incredible characters in them and
watching fett and shan move through the
underworld is something that i think is
going to be really intriguing as we get
further into the series i'd love to see
a sort of fight for the throne in this
show and though i don't think that will
happen i think there's more than enough
year to get fans invested if you've been
following the channel for a while now
then you'll know that we've covered all
the mandalorian episodes along with the
bad batch and this slots perfectly in
with them and telling a tale of someone
just trying to make their way in the
galaxy watching boba fett return is
something that fans have wanted for so
long and i'm so glad that we're getting
it in a series that has as high
production values as this one does say
what you want about the marvel shows but
i always feel like the star wars
episodes especially feel like films and
they have such an authenticity to them
this was a brilliant way to kickstart
the season and i of course will be back
next week to talk about the second
episode in the series now i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts so make sure
you comment below and let me know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the
spider-man 4k trilogies on the 30th of
december and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our brighton of the hawkeye finale which
will be linked on screen right now we
talked about all the easter eggs and
where the series could be going next so
definitely go check it out right after
this without the way thank you for
sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see you on the next one take
care peace